cheap tricks surrender is a 70 song
through and through it was released in
1978 which is only four years before
1982 but let me put it this way you'd be
annoyed if a movie opening in 2002
played tub-thumping why cuz it's from a
totally different thing decade is
Cooper's little sister running the most
successful lemonade stand of all time
also it's pretty convenient that
everyone paid her in exact quarters and
Cooper's little sister looks a bit too
much like Sam Brenner
Cooper's mom and Sam's dad have some
splainin to do there's a pattern to have
a movie I don't see you sure as hell do
this isn't the last time in this film
where we'll hear about patterns yet no
one takes time to properly explain them
even when our lives depend on it
I how's that in there looks like we have
a one of these things and not like the
other situation on our hands hey sure
Andy actually wanted Cooper's the real
champion here those machines are hard
and there are no patterns why is he
getting so much media attention and
being followed by these two leather
pants models we forgotten this is a
video game competition and not an RNC
debate this is a fugly contest I'd be in
chubbo what is this goofy ass accent
he's using maybe it's a speech
impediment are you saying all dwarves
have speech impediments that's racist
it's totally tubular oh come on
didn't Sandler exercises 80s nostalgia
demons in the wedding singer here's how
the conversation went to get dan Aykroyd
in the movie damn Adam I read the script
it's awful I won't be in the movie Adam
come on I'll give you some of my money
that I don't deserve damn alright but
you have to use my vodka in one scene
Adam deal to be included in a
compilation of 1982's news events and
popular culture if all that is included
how did the aliens interpret the video
game as a declaration of war
they clearly send them other stuff that
should have put the video game
competition into context but then there
wouldn't be a plot to this movie that's
not much of one now you say well to
check I don't have two girls that look
like that standing behind me while I
play video games was there an award
ceremony where they headed out
participation trophies just before this
by the looks of it there are a lot of
people with the same trophy sitting in
the audience in a video game
championship the players still have to
put in quarters for some reason the top
two players in the world right now our
children roughly the same age in the
same country the original arcade game
Donkey Kong famously does not have an
ending and just goes to a kill screen
after level 22 unless there's a time
limit we do not see there's no reason
for this game to be over at all
congratulations on coming in second even
though there are monitors everyone can
watch for each player it feels like no
one knows who won until he says this
I was actually thinking Samantha Fox
nice but she's no she and Easton there's
always McDonald
oh come on didn't Sandler exercise his
80s nostalgia boner demons three minutes
earlier in this movie how about Scarlett
Johansson what are we doing right now
was this almost self awareness coming
from Adam Sandler and couldn't that
question apply to the movie itself jaw
is killing me ma'am what kind of job did
Kevin James have that would be killing
it
UPS guy zookeeper mall cop president
Kevin James as the president well Donald
Trump might be president soon so this
really doesn't seem that far-fetched at
all my god there's no camera by his legs
so where are the shots of the kids
coming from I wish it worked that way in
real life every time an elected official
makes a gaffe they quickly turn to the
camera and it zooms in like they're
about to say live from New York it's
Saturday night does the president just
go to bars with his friends he grew up
with it would probably be a better idea
for president Cooper to just invite his
buddies to meet him in the privacy of
the White House where they could
definitely have drinks without costing
the taxpayers money does this bar have a
valet where is this kiosk and umbrella
maybe Sam just hired this guy to take
his van to cover some of his
appointments while he had beers with the
president so you just need to channel
your genius into something for Doc do I
mean you were incredible at video games
back in the day but all we know about
Sam is that he was good at video games I
know a lot of people who are very good
at video games modern and more
complicated video games and I wouldn't
even come close to classifying them as
geniuses hello I am a nerd from the nerd
brigade do you have to say that every
time you show up at a house if I want to
get paid yes no one in the history of
Geek Squad and Geek Squad like Services
has ever been required to say some
demoralizing statement before delivering
their services my dad cheated on my mom
with his 19 year old Pilates instructor
obnoxious TMI cake cliche is here and
this time he's ginger no I can hear a
little more you got any pictures I'm
kidding I'm sorry to hear that
Adam Sandler deadpan saying something
that immediately takes it back Lachey
but seriously he does this all the time
thought him you were gonna be like one
of those hot when we first met in high
school but then let herself go and got a
potbelly and turkey neck with a hairy
chin more like whoa I should have
brushed my teeth before I left the house
this morning did you really not brush
your teeth this morning isn't really the
most important thing to respond to after
that speak
how about excuse me but I find you very
inappropriate I will be calling your
supervisor more inappropriate things
that she for no reason finds endearing
we're under attack what was on his
computer screen I hope it was big bold
letters that read we're under attack
what do you
talking about she decides to leave her
kid in the room with a strange man who
was just creepily checking her out and
then walks back in acting like they're
being cute talking about video games
together not judging but what are you
doing in the closet is this the third or
fourth inappropriate thing he said while
he's there
I lost Ken I'm mostly crying oh well I'm
drinking and she answers him honestly
this guy could actually be a real creep
or rapist and you're just telling him
you're vulnerable and drinking in a room
with only one escaped but why in the
closet because I don't want Matty to see
me well she told him literally
everything about his dad cheating on her
well damaged do you think this could do
Shirley out of this sippy cup couldn't
she just drink it straight out of the
bottle or was that not pathetic enough
so if an alien creature shoots an
earthly object of any kind it turns into
tiny Allspark cubes
why would shooting something cause it to
take on the properties of the thing that
shot it even the fire it creates is all
QB this is way too complicated for this
film I'm sure we will never get an
answer took most of his arm to get
pixelated before he started screaming
it's just where I thought I'd be at this
point my wife spilling your guts to a
middle-aged stranger in tech support is
a pretty low point but does this person
have no friends whoa are you trying to
kiss me violet let's Sam get 90% of the
way in for a kiss before she realizes
what a bad idea this is let's just say I
was a billionaire and we were out on my
giant yacht in the middle of the
Mediterranean sipping champagne and I
went in to kiss you would you have kiss
me back then why is she acting like he
duped her with this question she could
just say it's because you're kind of
gross and not charming it has nothing to
do with your profession but instead she
seems like she's kind of into this guy
which I got by I don't think Sam has
ever brushed his teeth us normal teeth
brushes know that he is missing two key
ingredients toothpaste and water
whoa she went from zero to psycho in 3.4
seconds and I think she went to psych
though as soon as she was remotely
interested in Sam Brenner is she not the
least bit curious as to why he's also
going to the White House I know they
have AV needs there but I feel like a
high ranking military official should
assume it's not the nerd squad and
subsequently question him instead of
making faces Colonel Van Patten and
she's military brass what a
serendipitous coincidence why are you
following me
they're far enough into the West Wing at
this point for her question to be long
overdue obvious use of moonwalk stunt
double our Air Force Base in Guam was
attacked does Brenner have a certain
level of security clearance that allows
him to moonwalk into the Oval Office and
have the president just tell him secrets
yeah
this up me yes you come here being the
president Cooper has the entire US
military at his disposal and there is no
one in the military or any branch of
government many of which are filled with
nerdy video gamers that could identify
what video game that sound was from can
I sit in your chair no you can but you
can't mess around with my laptop that
probably has classified information on
it like the video you just told him to
watch and let's poke Java get it out
who's Galaga can I really send a movie
that is clearly very dumb for this
Admiral one of the highest ranking
officials in the military who says
things like this the answer was yes if
this sign is telling the truth
Brenner should definitely not be allowed
in this room and better yet the door
should be closed and guarded by the
Secret Service MIT yes Mississippi
Institute of Technology if Sam Brenner
is going to make up a school he should
at least make one up that sounds better
like South Harmon Institute of
Technology mr. Brenner here was the
world Galaga champion he apparently the
arcade tournament where he became the
Galaga champion was the only one that
was ever held and he Ludlow in the fire
blaster set all the arcade game records
that are available to set and at this
version though Blue Lagoon even though
we're out of the 80s we're not done with
80s references does she really get to
talk twice she's not even at the
grown-ups table Adam Sandler is supposed
to be the love interest for her keep in
mind so I suggest the man in the orange
shorts leave the room immediately
Admiral who was just erratically saying
crazy things is suddenly the voice of
reason Gandalf and Harry Potter in the
same room imagine not only is that not
even close and aggressively unfunny how
has Brenner not been forcefully ejected
from the White House at this point
Brenner has a brief moment of
super-strength and hits Ludlow so hard
he flies to the back of the van defies
the latch on the back door and lands in
the street his name is Bao Bao is that a
Pacific Islander name no I don't think
so is it lazy racism in an Adam Sandler
movie yes yes it is
something peculiar interrupted Sophia
Bush's sexy shenanigans now I guess I
can wrap my head around no one watching
One Tree Hill reruns but no government
agency was able to intercept that
message that Ludlow just happened to
record this actually may seem plausible
after meeting the president and his top
ranking military officials inhabitants
of Earth the winner takes the losers
planet so aliens find a time capsule
that's been shot into the infinity of
outer space take it seriously and head
to earth to basically play a game still
slightly less implausible than Sandler
ending up with Michelle Monaghan okay I
lost about halfway through why does
Madonna I want to take over our planet
the President of the United States got
lost watching something that I not the
president was able to comprehend he
no I was only half paying attention this
Indian kid is somehow not brownface Rob
Schneider granted we'd send that too and
probably add ten to fifty cents but
seems like Rob Schneider needs to be in
this somehow even if it's to take an
Indian actors job away why this kid
the last trophy was taken from the
actual site that was attacked this kid
was a few miles away they must also be
upset that he wasn't played by one of
Adam Sandler's friends and then I was
watching you through a window
not only does brother get to be in areas
with no security clearance but now so
does Ledlow and he's clearly unstable so
these creatures are made from
intelligent light energy that doesn't
really check out because light is in
traditional matter it is photons that
have properties of both waves and
particles that carry energy proportional
to the radiation frequency but has zero
rest mass yet these things seem to be
solid and have force and that doesn't
really explain why everything the light
energy cubes come into contact with turn
into more light cubes what I'm sorry I'm
being told to stop trying to inject
photon physics into an Adam Sandler
movie about arcade games where Kevin
James is the president they calm down
pretty quick when we hit them with some
supercharged light particles
she said they calm down in her magical
light cannons simply destroyed it and
the slot seeking us flawed premise of
the film in Compton 80s references seem
like it's a movie for Gen Xers but
appear I'll joke about sluts makes it
seem like it's for thirteen-year-old
boys how about we meet in the middle and
say it's for no one is that how you got
into the Mississippi Institute of
Technology
violet seems like she should be an
intelligent woman lieutenant colonel
apparent quantum physicist yet she keeps
flirt fighting with this guy who was
clearly a loser asshole can anyone just
bring their friends or kids to
top-secret military labs Maddie's old
enough to be left alone in her office
but here's fine I guess president Cooper
doesn't seem to have a moment of doubt
for bringing Ludlow into the situation
nor do any of the other military
officials say this man is unstable and
shouldn't be allowed in here but
suddenly it might be comin in handy to
saving our planet they still seem to be
operating under the notion that Brenner
and Ludlow are the only ones that are
capable of helping in this situation
because they compete it in but didn't
really win an arcade gaming championship
in a suburb of DC over 30 years ago
someone should tell them that there are
thousands of gamers out there who are
probably more capable during this
montage they go over things that people
who have walked past in arcade would
know you don't want to get hit by a
boulder in asteroids or you can't climb
a ladder with the hammer and Donkey Kong
what about those patterns those seem to
be extremely important yet neither
Brenner nor Ludlow are taking the time
to explain them where they go-go-going
to so quickly are they running to the
middle of the field just to stand
try not to cause total panic if he's
interested in not causing total panic
why would they aggressively send troops
into that low
with no explanation also Sean Bean isn't
dying in this scene I don't want to hear
another word out of you this is the
first military guy to say the right
thing to Ludlow I had two days to do
things never done before on this planet
sir this lieutenant colonel with the
help of a robot with a head shaped like
the alien from alien with an eyes
flashlights in two days at this point in
the movie okay sure
just remember who you're talking to
Missy thanks to the military for
stepping in to make the gamers seem
positively enlightened regarding gender
politics isn't it a coincidence that the
character Sandler plays just so happened
to wear the same ill-fitting schlub
clothes he favors okay this has very
little to do with video game knowledge
they're just shooting guns at something
which is what the military trains for
normally not only should they be able to
handle this but they should be able to
handle it better than Brenner and Ludlow
those guns are probably heaviest yet out
of shape Brenner just grabs it and
starts accurately shooting like this the
same as using the controls on an arcade
game we're the only ones who can do this
there are probably thousands of people
that can do this and in a normal world
some of those people would be in the
military let the Nerds take over
fantasy wish fulfillment cliche Brenner
and Ludlow or shooting these things
right above their heads and light energy
pixels are raining down on them and
they're not getting hurt aren't these
the same objects they had in a
containment chamber in the lab I guess
being an arcade game champion exempts
you from looking while shooting
so they actually collecting points here
why are these numbers appearing this is
mostly just a just don't die situation
very convenient that their 2d gaming
skills translated so well into the third
dimension why does this simply decide to
go rogue that's not part of the game old
person not noticing mayhem going on
behind them because they are hard of
hearing or too focused on their mundane
tasks cliche also wholly overuse of
cliche cliche Brenner decides to
rapid-fire kill the centipede moments
before it gets to the kid when he
clearly had the chance to do it in the
old lady's apartment earlier and didn't
also why is this child alone on the
street at night is he a drug dealer oh
look Dan Akroyd slicker looks like Adam
Sandler held up his end of the deal and
then the old woman then the duck hunt
dog ran away together it lived happily
ever after
I say this because we never see the duck
hunt dog again also I thought all the
aliens face they're done stuff they got
from 1982 how do they know about duck
hunt or Madonna in fact there are a lot
of suspiciously 1984 things coming down
from the aliens in this movie not
hacking cell phone companies and adding
one of those fees you see on your bill
every week would have no idea what it is
made about 50 million before he was
convicted we haven't convicted anyone
working for AT&T or Verizon for doing
that same thing in this universe or
theirs
I hope he don't zap me with his space go
Peter just Peter no pick one of them
we'll set up a coffee serena williams
and we are closed it's funny easy
because powerful successful women are
nothing more than prizes do be want
you'll say it every time it appears the
right stuffs hero walk cliche this time
with too much fog couldn't do a second
take is it necessary to the aliens since
a Fairplay that the cars be the same
color as the ghosts in pac-man and we're
hauling on many ghosts how long have
they known that this battle was going to
be pac-man regardless any amount of time
seems like not enough time to develop
light particle forcefield whatever she
said cars why did she need to buckle
them in I know Sandler movies have
insanely juvenile protagonists but this
is ridiculous
does he need a mean mommy lady to wipe
his butt to not lose right you do smell
good he's just as obnoxious as he's ever
been but now she's charmed by his
garbage personality for no logical
reason I love how they hired Jane
Krakowski to not really say anything for
the entire movie the military didn't
clear the area which will make this
battle more difficult oh also loss of
civilian life man it's a bad guy
did no one proofread the script before
they made this movie they should know by
now that pac-man is the bad guy what did
they think their ghost mini coopers were
forward also pac-man shouldn't be the
bad guy
you play the game as pac-man not the
ghosts they should be in a giant pac-man
car looking for dots and avoiding ghosts
not ghost cars looking to get pac-man
Pokemon is not bad I created him to
bring joy to all the people of the world
guess I should also explain the Toru
Iwatani should know that that is not
actually pac-man it's an alien that's
made to look like pac-man he's my son
Toru your itani has clearly gone mad
he's gonna get his hand bitten off now
it was in the trailer that was some
twisted pinocchio-geppetto stuff right
there for the amount of time it took for
you to say that you think a lap or two
might come out of me but damned if it
didn't not only are these guys experts
at video games and light cannon shooting
but they are also expert stunt drivers
Pacman's got 10 seconds where he can eat
us did violet design the ghost cars to
be compatible with power pellets because
that seems like something you would want
to avoid if that man is faster than the
ghost
how has pac-man not eaten Brenner yet
and now with nothing but a Mini Cooper
and arcade game knowledge Brenner is
going to back through a concrete wall
and land on an adjacent roof without
damaging his ghost car the military has
been unsuccessful of securing any area
throughout this entire movie I don't
know
when we were them failing or them
actually pulling this off
why have they decided to develop this
guy as kind of a sign antagonist after
we have made it two-thirds of the way
through the movie maybe they just paid
Brian Cox for a certain amount of screen
time and they wanted to get their
money's worth you had a pretend you're
the guy and you don't want to die
I know Brenner is gonna act like this is
silly but it was basically what he was
doing when he fought the centipede in
the old lady's apartment and when he
defeated pac-man as soon as they
introduced these arcade characters to
the real world they threw out all the
precious patterns why is it that all the
other arcade characters are destroyed
forever when they get broken up but
Qbert gets to bust into a million pieces
and just come right back together and
seem happy about it no one moves to
impeach the president after these dance
moves you and Will Smith talked about
this they promised me an island if I did
this I assume she's talking about being
in the movie I don't know why but Qbert
and a tux really makes me upset
the filmmakers wanted to get their
money's worth
so they made Tony award-nominated actor
Josh GAD Singh in the movie
you know what +10 sins for any other
extraneous eighties reference that
appears just in case I lose count
someone with your skills you'd be better
off inventing technology rather than
installing it I must have missed Brenner
skills for inventing technology as the
guys good at video games and went to a
fictional school in Mississippi you know
I had my shot when I was a kid their
kids how was that his last chance he was
12 years old for him playing video games
was a hobby and he just happened to be
really good at it
and why am i explaining this to a grown
man who can't hear me a cop fished these
out of the East River the night you fell
in there's no way someone could find a
pair of sunglasses in the East River
there are things a lot larger than a
that have yet to be recovered the
pac-man cheat code for SuperSpeed you're
a cheater yes he's a cheater but he was
driving a pink car he had no way to
input a cheat code into where did violet
get a jumpsuit did they have a lady
jumpsuit just in case one showed up who
could help or did they stay up all night
making her a jumpsuit they tried to take
me to some underground bunker so I went
wrong so the chubby president in a
Chewbacca mask was able to escape the
secret service and also find an arcade
jumpsuit of his own along the way Ludlow
gets his wish
lady Lisa is real and this really works
out for him because she isn't pixelated
she's Ashley Benson Ashley Benson
doesn't speak during this entire film
making her the greatest actress in the
movie this is the only video game
monster that turned into a human being
presumably so this very moment wouldn't
be so disgusting but it's still kind of
disgusting one day you suck at isn't he
like the best in the world at everything
and just the second best at Donkey Kong
let's give him a little credit mr.
president pee Burt
also thanks to the movie speed joke I
had to write Qbert urinates in my notes
plus two sins for shaming me unless the
aliens have lessen the gravity on the
spaceship violet Brenner and Cooper have
all suddenly become parkour experts good
of Donkey Kong to let them have this
conversation during the battle also how
did Eddie put cheat codes into an arcade
game and I don't remember any cheats for
classic arcade Donkey Kong that would
allow you to get a super high school by
the way on earth three people are taking
on an entire swarm of videogame bad guys
and one of them used to be one of the
bad guys so can see the bind I'm in
reset fight
now that Brenner has had a small pep
talk he becomes amazing at the game and
easily defeats it
okay fine why does Qbert need help he
just popped back to life from being
flattened oh and we never see the aliens
I guess it would have cost too much to
animate all these game characters and
aliens lady Lisa no our weird hero gets
a sex toy after all what a great message
and no one else is weirded out by this
that was just Qbert this movie is now
officially so bad Adam Sandler is
sitting it from within Serena Williams
was pretty disgusted with Eddie at the
awkward adult prom that happened earlier
yet she's waiting in the Lincoln Bedroom
for a three-way with Eddie and Martha
Stewart also how did Martha Stewart find
out about this three-way I could have
done without this that means Qbert
didn't become lady Lisa but was Qbert
just transformed to look like Lady Lisa
which means Ludlow Qbert good night
everybody
what's it gonna be like up there 200
degrees in sunlight - 200 the shade
canyons of razor sharp rock
unpredictable gravitational conditions
unexpected eruptions things like that
okay so the scary environment manageable
thanks that's all yes I scarce
environment imaginable you feel you've
been rehabilitated oh yes
want to attach your name to a world
record when you want your name written
into history you have to pay the price
typical Roman I wanna get this money
come on
thanks for being my friend thank you for
being afraid
and
I've been waitin to do this since 1982
I'm gonna kill anybody since 1984 you
want to have my name beyond my blood